Now I'd like to share
some of my favorite
#MyTeacherIsWeird stories
from you guys. Here we go.
This first one is from
@ngblaze44.
[ Laughter ]
-That's not weird.
That's great.
-"We got a deal."
-Yeah.
-Yeah, that's a cool teacher.
This one is from @marcussilva73.
[ Applause ]
A little weird.
This one's from @Matt-Iorio.
[ Laughter ]
Wait. What?
[ Russian accent ]
"I have the documents.
Meet me in the cafeteria."
-[ Russian accent ]
"Your cover is blown."
-This one is from
@jmar-dagenius.
-Ohh!
-Aah! Gosh!
-What the...?!
Come on, shake a leg!
-Gosh.
Went out on a limb here.
[ Laughter ]
Come on.
-This one's from
@Dougeben090900.
Dougie Ben.
-Dougie Ben.
[ Tuba plays sad foghorn ]
What?
Ohh!
-"Twigs."
-"As I was saying, you guys,
uh, neon gas is a..."
This one's from @AnpanVero.
[ Laughter ]
What?
You can't -- You can't do that.
-That's not cool.
-The demon's last name.
-[ Hissing ]
-Tssss!
I wonder why they got a divorce.
-This last one
is from @-lola-bee.
There you have it. Those are our
"Tonight Show" Hashtags.
To check out more
of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.